siri wird es akkurat oder accurate
betont ich habe die tage schon mal ein
video hochgeladen in dem ich ein
youtube-user parodiert hat
und dieses video kam relativ gut bei
euch an und ich glaube dass deswegen
einige andere youtube user das gleiche
gemacht haben
und deswegen zeige ich euch heute eine
neue parodie von ihr unter herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren hier
heute zu einem neuen video was ich jetzt
heute hochladen werde hier wie vorhin
schon im intro gesagt bin ich mal wieder
durch die weiten von youtube gestöbert
und habe nach konkreter parodie gesucht
und habe auch eine gefunden von einer
userin die das ganze tatsächlich vor
drei tagen hochgeladen hat das heißt es
ist sehr sehr frisch noch alles nicht
würde sagen klammer gar nicht lange drum
rum sondern wir schauen uns erst mal die
ersten szene an ihr intro und schauen ob
sie das gut gemacht hat da müssen wir
dann denken wir dass die willkommen
heute ist er in einem video wie ist dein
name gewinnt meinte irgendwas mit
männern dingen oder so glaube ich erst
mal ein wenig korrekt dass du diese das
ist auch so ein standard dinge dass ich
immer den hier mache das macht jeder
bisher nie da parodiert das zeigt dass
ich so im video den fokus verstelle ich
komm ja ich mache es doch man dort etwas
glaube ich überhaupt an dich korrekt
danke dir dass du die parodie gemacht
hast du hast das kannst du vor allem
auch von einem greenscreen gemacht oder
ich meine wenn man sich das hier mal
anguckt sieht man dass sie quasi in
meinem zimmer sitzt und das hat sich war
sehr einfach dadurch gemacht dass sie
sich vor einem greenscreen gesagt
übrigen screen ich habe einen grünen
pullover von anti held an
aber wissen welcher schon besser ist
jetzt kommt ein werbevideo für die leute
wie schon mehrmals gesagt tag durch den
ersten sechs in den kalender einer geht
es eine sommer kollegen zu suchen wir
schauen uns das video mal weiter an ich
hab mich aber darum gebeten wenn wir mal
was hast du oder beziehungsweise ich die
leute darum gebeten videos 161 etwas ist
ex hunter oder exakter oder irgendwie
was ich sage doch immer twitter oder ist
exakter irgendwie ist das wir schauen
weiter ich habe euch aber darum gebeten
mir videos einzusenden und er den
hashtag mendig reagiert und auf die
werden wir jetzt reagieren jetzt um
genau zu sein in diesem moment
also was sie bisher in hier wirklich
sehr sehr gut gemacht hat es halt dieses
hey ich habe euch übrigens jeder der
mich parodiert dieses format eigentlich
wo ich auf videos von euch reagiere ich
das mal wieder machen lassen und weil
480.000 kommt machen wir eine folge was
sie auf jeden fall auch noch gut gemacht
hat ist dass sie gesagt hat ja das video
kommt heute also jetzt also jetzt werde
ich das machen und vor allem auch dieses
das hab ich wirklich in letzter zeit in
nahezu jedem video also man weiß
mittlerweile bei meinen videos wirklich
genau ok luca sagt hallo mein name ist
luca dann sagt er was los ist was er
heute machen geht der kommt dann kommt
quasi der haupthalle beziehungsweise der
wirkliche inhalt des videos sondern am
ende klappt ich halte jedoch jetzt kommt
das auto dann bedanke ich mich fürs
zuschauen et cetera pp ist es bei
anderen youtube auch so schaut halt sehr
sehr wenig andere youtuber aber wenn
jetzt das wirklich jedes mal so
durchgetaktet nur dieser inhalt
mittendrin der hauptteil ist anders aber
diese parodie weiter
der polizist der gleichen farbe wie
meine augen oder nehmen sie nicht so gut
würde ich sagen wir auch gleich mal an
und ich finde dass ich hier an der
kamera so fuchtel ich habe nämlich kein
stativ und deswegen schwebt die kamera
also ein bisschen komische perspektive
habe ich angefangen amilly ersten video
ok wahrscheinlich schwebt die kamera
oder ist halt auch so eine standard luca
sache also immer wenn ich eigentlich
hier war in meiner familie zu hause bin
mache ich ja relativ häufig dieses luca
reagiert format und ich vergesse immer
meinen stativ in köln in meiner
studentenbude weil es ist einfach so
groß und sperrig und ich denke eine
maultasche schon gepackt alles ist drin
ich war mal losen dann auf dem weg den
ich mir so vertiefen und deswegen
entschuldige ich mich halt einfach voll
häufig dafür dass die kamera irgendwie
auf einem karton steht oder auf meiner
wäsche oder offene menschen
du arschloch böse gemeint aber ewig
wieso alle standorte in videos
vollkommen hat sie einfach mit drin wenn
ich diese parodie von ihr bisher
beschreiben würde würde ich einfach nur
sagen das ist der test in die parodie so
gut alter also warten wir gehen wir
durch was sich jetzt wieder alles
richtig gemacht hat sie hat einfach so
eine typische einblendung enorm so man
filmt irgendwie also eine typische
anwendung ist ja eigentlich wie ich ein
gesendet bekommen okay der vielen ging
was und dann schmeißt irgendwas dahin
seifen zerrissener sticker von mir oder
eine pizza oder ein stück scheiße oder
ein joghurt oder so da hat sie sogar
eine pizza genommen weil jeder weiß hey
ich liebe pizza und einer explosion am
ende das ist nicht wahr
die parodie es echt krank gut aber wir
schauen mal wie sie jetzt darauf
reagieren wird also er wirft seine pizza
ins klo und die explodiert dann es ist
so verdammt gut gemacht das muss man
einfach mal sagen sie hat das sogar mit
dem randen suchen so dass sie wenn sie
irgendwie was sagen denn musik
ausblenden dass mit run somit weg zoomen
und vor allem auch diese reaktion so von
wegen er wirft seine witze und die
explodierten
es ist das hast du sehr sehr gut heißt
das gerät oder actuate wir fragen was
ihr event paar sekunden später siri wird
es akkurat oder accurate betont wichtig
für mich bei allen die mir nicht glaubt
ich habe es ja so ausgesprochen
er sagt mein iphone akkus 50 prozent
geladen korrekt danke dir serie auf
jeden fall an der stelle deshalb will
ich so auf die es immer zu zählen
wir wissen trotz noch nicht wie es
betont wird ok hätte man das auch
geklärt so ist sagen wir probieren das
jetzt einfach mal aus und ist wirklich
funktioniert deswegen haben wir jetzt
eine zahl stellt euch einfach vor da
hinten ist eine toilette würde ich sagen
werfen
jetzt einfach mal weg ich liebe parodie
hersteller danach sei wieder sehr gut
gemacht dass man hier selber auch
relativ häufig das einfach wenn
einblendungen kommen die man ihnen
nachstellen kann wenn irgendwelche leute
tanzen oder irgendwas bescheuertes
machen mache ich das aber nach und ich
bin gespannt wie gut dass jetzt machen
wir ist also schauen wir uns das jetzt
mal an
aber irgendwie passiert da nichts das
man merkt dass das ein ganz ganz neue
parodie ist wie ich hatte nämlich genau
das gleich in unserem letzten luca
reagiert video von mir vielleicht auch
daran habe ich so eine stiftung die nach
hinten geworfen und dann sagt er da
hinten rum diese taten so hey da
passiert gar nicht sein dass diese
explosion hallte gekommen hat sie hier
genauso nachgestellt finde ich sehr sehr
geil aber ich würde sagen wir hast du
jetzt mal ein bisschen schneller durch
das ganze video also wir schauen mal wie
sie jetzt weitermacht und der parodie
was machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
video dass er dich nie besser machen
können ich denke mir immer so in jeder
szene okay jetzt hat sie das schon sehr
gut nachgestellten irgendwann hat sich
um diese standard sachen die ich immer
mache bewegen sind die halt vorbei so es
gibt nicht mehr dann haut sich das mit
dem klatschen raus mach ich aber weil so
enorm bescheuerten ein wer du bist halt
die heime und konnte danach ich so
wirklich hammergeil bin sehr sehr stolz
auf dich hätte ich nie damit gerechnet
aber heute war wirklich der tag wo mir
echt talentierte videos eingesendet
wurden sage ich auch immer in jedem
video sage ich hey haben wie
rechtsorientierte videos an also in dem
video eben gerade hat ja ein helm ist
eine brustwarze gespielt das zeigt mir
eben auch dass so viele leute da draußen
so richtig talentiert sind dann sehe ich
mich an und denke mir nur so dass ich
ziemlich talentlos bin jetzt war eine
komplett andere sache
also hat sie auch wiedersehen nach
gemacht und ich finde sie redet wie
kelly oder ich weiß nicht schaut euch
mal das telefonieren jahren dann sehe
ich mich an und denke mir immer so dass
ich ziemlich talentlos bilden das hört
sich für mich genauso an
kelly also ich schaue jetzt nicht jedes
video von kelly aber ich habe sie halt
schon öfters mal getroffen und mit ihr
schon öfters mal geredet und in meinen
augen und er meint rohr anhört es
genauso an wie kelly also kelly ja was
soll ich könnte jetzt sagen wird
überhaupt nichts damit zu tun gerade ich
meine ich hab ja auch schon an mir rum
gespielt aber noch nie noch nie an
meinen lippen ich habe angst mail den
level 1 zu klemmen weil ich bin
tollpatsch und da passiert das sehr
häufig es ist ein richtiger luke ray
ich habe das schon so häufig in diesem
lokal reagiert videos gesagt so heja
wenn ich fragen bekommen hab irgendwie
von wegen fährst du fährst du wakeboard
oder so habe ich mal gesagt nee ich bin
übels spaß ich würde mich locker nochmal
und mir alles brechen und genau das hat
sie jetzt auch wieder mit aufgenommen
also userin mit antic ich weiß nicht
genau wie videos unten verlegen diesmal
wäre ich sogar wirklich verlinken
bei der letzten parade ist nicht
verlinkt aber als bisher sehr gut
gemacht haben auch schon zum ersten
videos eher ein gesendet wurde
na ja es wird nicht wirklich ein
gesendet sondern es wurden oder x5
zerlegt dahin gepackt mir wird dann halt
nur gesagt hier schau dir das mal an
da hat jemand ne mail ente crafter
parodie gemacht und darauf reagieren man
sieht wirklich sehr sehr krass dass die
sich auch mein letztes luca reagiert
bezieht als ich meine paris war gerade
mal drei tage alt nur da habe ich
nämlich auch am ende gesagt ja das video
wurde jetzt nicht von dem user so
eingesetzt sondern wie gut der link dazu
eigene senden dann habe ich quasi am
ende der luca reagiert folge noch mal
auch eine parodie von mir reagiert und
sie wird das jetzt quasi genau so machen
also ihr müsst verstehen sie tut ja
jetzt quasi im video gerade so als wäre
sie ich und versuche das so ein bisschen
nachzumachen und jetzt reagiert sie auf
die parodie von sich also von mir ihr
werdet es sehen also sie reagiert quasi
auf sich selbst und außerdem habe ich
jetzt endlich verstehen dass sie am
anfang meint und zwar der x1 der link
ich weiß zwar nicht was ich selbst da
ist allerdings dass die willkommen heute
sein video ich hab ich aber exakter
darum gebeten mir videos einzusenden und
in den herstellerländern reagiert und
auf gewinn
reagieren jetzt um genau zu sein in
diesem moment
[Musik]
man sieht natürlich gar nicht dass ein
mitglied spring gemacht ist aber
ansonsten macht ist gut das einzige was
ich eben kritisieren würde wäre das hier
eben gar nicht so aussieht wie ich ja
das ist wirklich sehr sehr krassen
wirklich wieder genauso gewesen die
meine letzte luca reagiert folge also
auch mit dem klatsch und so das habe ich
auch am ende gemacht bei dem typen der
mich da parodiert hat ich kann hier
wirklich nicht viel kommentieren ich
kann nur die ganze zeit lachen und sagen
ja hinaus so wenig das ist eine gute
party ich werde euch das video auf jeden
fall unten im video beschreibung
verlinken oder auch nicht ich höre das
ist ein richtiger luca ich habe letztes
mal gesagt ich verlinke euch die parodie
habe es einfach nicht gewaltig vergessen
sorry dass ich würde sagen lasst alle
mann fit leichter falls es euch gefallen
hat das natürlich auch gerne ein
leichter wenn ihr finde dich sollte das
öfter machen und ansonsten könnt ihr
auch gerne noch einen daumen nach oben
gebe nirgendwo daumen nach oben geben
wenn die biker wochen pizza hier werde
ich gar nicht einblenden und irgendwo
eine video beschreibung ist auch meinen
shop verlinkt da könnt ihr mir gerne
mehr cash beweisen damit ich mehr cash
habe da könnt ihr gerne überall drauf
klicken oder auch nicht okay zu dieser
letzten situation beziehungsweise dieser
letzten stelle kann ich noch ein
bisschen was kritisieren also das
erstmal gut gemacht mit dem klatschen am
ende das mal ja auch immer ich finde ich
sage nicht so häufig last night gleich
sagst du allerhöchstens zwei mal im
video aber das jetzt sollte standard
youtuber sache dass man sagt egal
bleibt also leute lasst ein leichter
wenn es euch gefällt lasten like das ist
auf jeden fall mal in der liga aber ich
mache am ende des videos nie den hier
weil ich finde das immer voll blöd weil
ich finde das macht keinen sinn weil das
bild wird ja nicht schwarz am ende
sondern bleibt mir dann andere videos
auf oder dann kommt dieses auto plating
deswegen verstehe ich nicht dieses jahr
auf die kamera drauf fassen was ich halt
am ende mache ist quasi einfach nur
irgendwas allem wenn er geld klick und
ich hielt aber naja leute ich würde an
dieser stelle auch sagen danke an lantiq
für diese parodie canalis unten verlinkt
beziehungsweise das video chat ist auf
jeden fall mal aus dass die schöne grüße
da wenn euch diese parodie
beziehungsweise dieses video gefallen
hat lassen vettel ja ich würde sagen
wenn ihr keinen bock auf den leib dazu
lassen könnte
daumen hoch das bin ich ja in der tat
hier findet ihr oben ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf sie könnte
meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren fast
keine videos mehr da oben findet auch
meinen job eingeblendet wie gesagt erst
sechster kommen neue sommer sachen mode
ist ein anderes video unkommentiert mal
parodie wenn er jetzt noch dran seid bis
zum ende